it doesn't seem like hogwarts legacy
will be hitting store shelves anytime
soon but did you know there's actually a
new harry potter video game that
released this year i know crazy right
honestly this is really bizarre to me
just how under the radar this game has
been so far you really have to be
looking for the information to find this
and i think one of the reasons is
because it still hasn't been released in
major territories like the united states
in europe but if you haven't heard harry
potter magic awaken is a wizarding world
video game that just recently had its
official launch but only in the
territories of china taiwan hong kong
and macau now from what i've read they
are planning to release in other
territories at some point including the
us the latest reports have indicated a
winter 2021 target for the territories
of thailand the philippines malaysia
singapore indonesia japan and south
korea but most of you listening to this
video right now at least according to my
analytics are from the americas and
europe so what about our territories
here americas and europe well there is a
sign that the us release could be
happening sooner than you may think so
make sure to stick around for that
because we'll definitely get into those
details before the end of the video as
far as the actual game itself goes this
is quite different from hogwarts legacy
it's an rpg card game for pc android and
ios and it's set 10 years after harry
potter's victory over voldemort in the
battle of hogwarts it was first
announced back in october of 2019 and is
being developed by netease and published
by wb under the port key games label
which yes this is the very same label
that hogwarts legacy will be published
under when it final releases hopefully
in 2022 so with magic awakens taking
place so close to the original series
there will actually be quite a few
familiar faces that we'll interact with
throughout the game our character's
journey starts similar to harry's when
the half giant rubius hagrid shows up to
deliver a letter of acceptance to a
young muggleborn hagrid then teaches
them about the wizarding world and joins
them on their first trip to diagon alley
the story really kicks off at the
sorting ceremony when a fellow first
year ivy warrington goes missing in
addition to solving that mystery players
will get to choose their hogwarts house
attend classes explore the castle and
even join the dueling club most of the
action and spell casting will be
centered on the game's card based combat
system normally i'll be honest i'm not
really into mobile games and i don't
play a lot of these card based strategy
rpg games but with this one being a
harry potter game they certainly have my
attention at the very least i will say
one thing i absolutely love about it
just from the videos i've seen just from
the trailer that you're seeing right now
is the art style it somehow manages to
nail that harry potter atmosphere and
overall sense of magic and wonder
despite being a rather refreshing take
on the series it kind of reminds me a
bit of the thai harry potter book covers
which are just absolutely gorgeous if
you haven't seen them i mean just look
at this probably my favorite covers out
of all the various hp translations now
even though it's technically a mobile
game they do actually have it for pc as
well so i was excited to see that they
have that in addition to the ios and
android versions which personally i
think this will really help the game
when it finally does release in the us
and europe and what's so bizarre to me
is how they're seemingly putting the us
the rest of the americas and europe on
the back burner despite the fact that
these are two of the biggest territories
for the harry potter franchise of course
there are certainly dynamics to the
mobile game market that i don't claim to
understand so maybe that has something
to do with it and why they're releasing
in certain territories before others and
of course it does take time to get an
accurate translation for the story and
all the dialogue they've created now i
mentioned at the start of the video that
there could be a sign the us release is
close or even imminent well it turns out
just a few weeks ago developer net ease
was holding interviews for the english
version of harry potter magic awakened
they were conducting two hour zoom
interviews with folks who could one
download the game to their phone two had
some mobile gaming experience and three
were fans of the harry potter series so
hopefully this is a sign that a full
release in the us and europe is much
closer than we think maybe even before
the end of 2021. of course the way
things are looking right now it is
really starting to seem like 2022 is
gonna be the year of harry potter at
least in the us hogwarts legacy the new
fantastic beasts movie and if this game
doesn't make it out here in 2021 then it
very well could be 2022 as well so it
could just be a massive year of harry
potter content which you know as fans
we're gonna absolutely love even though
i'd certainly like to get my hands on
the game a little bit sooner now
actually speaking of that though
you could play this game right now some
of you out there have actually already
played the game because it was in open
beta for a while unfortunately the
language barrier makes this harder for
those of us who only speak english but
i've talked with a few fans who have
actually played the game already in fact
you know what if you've already played
it be sure to leave a comment below and
let us know what you think so far is it
a harry potter game to keep on our radar
or is it not really worth your time how
have you found the overall mechanics of
the game let us know and if you're
interested in more harry potter content
be sure to check out the hogwarts legacy
playlist on the right side of your
screen now or if you're more in the mood
for some old school harry potter let's
plays then check out the playlist on the
left side of your screen as always thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon